everyone's worried about what's the ROI
what about the invisible ROI of actually
caring when you did something nice and
they didn't tweet back and you're like
ah Gary's full of crap his thesis
doesn't work but that person actually
said something in real life because oh
by the way all your traditional metrics
are built on that all the traditional
stuff you spend money on is factoring
all that stuff that you can't measure
and then everybody with Facebook and
Twitter everything wants a count every
click and every referral and everything
it's ridiculous when everybody says to
me what's the ROI of social media some
of you heard this for me I always say
what's the ROI of your mother
what's your live another because I'm
telling you right now the ROI of my mom
is everything the only reason I'm
standing here is because I was perfectly
parented I'm a ridiculous character that
my mom knew exactly what to do with I
failed every class being an immigrant
where every other immigrant child was
going to Harvard and Yale because when
you're an immigrant education is the
escape but my mom slipped me out and
executed against my skills and she
schlepped my [ __ ] baseball cards in
the snow at 6:00 in the morning to drive
me two hours to go to baseball card
shows so they are live my mom is the
whole [ __ ] thing and the reason I'm
gonna buy the Jets and do everything is